speaking of holding the line against
democrats radical agenda
newly elected gop congressmen are
banding together to form a squad of
their own
to be a check on aoc and her berrymanned
band of radicals
one of those members of the new freedom
force congressman elect burgess owens of
utah joins me now
i love being able to say congressman
elect congratulations burgess you're
such a nice guy and i'm so thrilled for
you
thank you thank you so much lisa i
appreciate that so what is the freedom
force
and what do you guys stand for you know
it's
it's interesting uh because we have a
group of people came in we're very very
diverse
different different backgrounds colors
races a whole bit
but what we all share in common is our
love for our country and what's so nice
about this freshman team and i just have
to thank the american people
across this country we flipped over 14
seats and we didn't lose one
uh and and it was a message from
america's people that we just want to
get back to basics we love our nation
and this group will be we'll be talking
against and
giving a contrast to the hard left we
have the freedom force versus squad
we have a group of people who believe in
our country believe in god country
family
uh respect for women and authority and
the other side it hates everything i
just mentioned
so i i think the great thing is that
american people drift toward the light
they're going to love our message
they're going to love the policies put
in place uh
the last segment you're talking about
the middle class we're all about make
sure middle class thrives
and i mean small businesses that means
we can keep our income get our kids
educated all those things that americans
want for
uh once for their next the next
generation and we're going to be able to
get a message out
in a very big way and i look forward to
that well and bridgette burgess
you mentioned the um diversity in the
freedom
force so but we've looked at you know
the past four years
all we've seen from the media they've
called president trump races they've
essentially said that he is hitler
however those attacks didn't work
because if you look at the numbers
president trump did
better than any other gop candidate
since 1960 with minorities
you look at among hispanics he improved
his margins in 78 of the 100 majority
hispanic districts in the country so why
do you think those attacks didn't really
resonate with minority voters
well because unlike the leftists which
are racist uh
american people believe in the same
thing we all want hope we want
opportunities we want the chance to get
out there
and work for our toward our dreams and
that's what that's what
the american people resonate to and
that's what he voted for
keep in mind this the freedom this
freedom force i'm talking about are
south korea um cuba iran
uh greece uh i grew up in tallahassee
florida and and byron
um donald came out of brook new york
in the same thing we've all dealt with
the harshness the evil of socialism and
marxism
and so we can talk from experience i'm
part of the generation that got
snookered by the left
uh byron is a is part of the generation
that's actually leaving the
plantation a big way so we can talk from
experience about how
devastating that ideology is and people
are going to resonate to it because we
all want to
have the opportunity to live our
american dream burgess i'd be remiss if
i didn't ask you about this one
so two nfl quarterbacks decided to take
a knee during the national anthem
yesterday on thanksgiving as you can see
there detroit lions quarterback matthew
stafford
and houston texas quarterback deshaun
watson right there
taking a knee you know burgess we're at
this point in the country
and if something like the flag can no
longer
unite us as a nation like what what
unites us
well that's the whole thing the left
wants to to make sure we're divided
the flag our games uh uh those things
sports all things bring us together why
do they want to divide us so much
because that's what the left does we the
people believe in harmony the the
leftists the socialist marxism wants to
divide us has always been the case
and they they thrive in giving people
misery and for those those
young players are making millions of
dollars decide they don't want to stand
let's let's take a list and see what
they're doing during off season are they
going to go in and help those
thousands of black americans who lost
their businesses or the hundreds of
black lives have been lost because of
the leftist demonstration and riots now
it's time for us to stop the the
good feelings let's get to work roll up
our sleeves and learn our history and
find out this is the greatest country in
history mankind
and and i'll be honest with you lisa i'm
done with the nfl
until they file the commissioner i'm not
watching anymore because we had
too many millions of americans paid the
price for us to have this great country
live in
to have these these liberal activists or
these uh
radical activists running in to fail
dividing us by by
allowing us to continue to go on stand
up stand up for the flag
and if you don't want to do that the
american people show us that we don't
really need your
nature business we don't need
entertainment i i wholeheartedly agree
with you i don't watch it anymore also
my old team washington redskins dropped
the redskins and now they have a stupid
generic
name so they are dead to me i i need to
find a new team so
i'm on the market versus i can't wait to
see what you do in the house i'm so
happy for you and it's so great to see
you
thank you look for this great team to be
very excited thank you so much lisa and
happy thanksgiving